hello thank you for joining me here
today it's a real pleasure and honor to
be giving this presentation and today
we'll be talking about breast cancer
genomics and how this has implications
for human populations and individuals so
of course we're also developing
commercial versions of some of these
assays that I'll be discussing and so
here's a disclosure but today's talk is
really going to focus on triple negative
breast cancers and if we take triple
negative breast cancers and separate
them from luminal or er positive breast
cancers then what we can see is that
it's about the fourth or fifth most
common killer of women in the United
States each year and therefore it
certainly requires attention and
deserves much of the attention that it's
getting so I should say people should be
feel free to ask questions throughout
the talk they'll come up on a whiteboard
that I'll see that I won't answer them
till the end so of course many of you
are familiar with our work on using gene
expression patterns to identify subtypes
of breast cancer over the years we've
used our intrinsic gene set to identify
luminal a luminal B basal-like her2
enriched and clawed and lo with our
focus on triple negative breast cancers
we focus in on a subset of these breast
cancers but I'm sure everyone can
appreciate that triple negative breast
cancer is still quite a heterogeneous
entity so to get at the what are triple
negative breast cancers in terms of
subtypes we published this paper
actually this year but it's also
important to keep in mind some of this
terminology because it can be confusing
and
and and what we are showing here by
looking at this set of a thousand
patients is that there's really two ways
to split this first is by clinical
status and then second ask about what
genomic subtypes are present based on
clinical status and that's typically
what's done so we looked at triple
negative breast cancers on the top part
here and then look at the subtype
Distribution present within triple
negatives alternatively you can split
patients according to intrinsic subtype
first and then ask what their triple
negative status is second so if we look
at triple negative breast cancers of
this 412 that were contained within this
dataset of a thousand the Florin away
majority subtype is the basal light
subtype and then you have a near equal
representation of the four other
intrinsic subtypes
so clearly basal likes are the are the
dominant entity and triple negatives
conversely if we looked at basal-like
breast cancers and then asked what is
their clinical status the majority of
basal like cancers about 70 percent are
triple negative however that also means
that about 30 percent are not triple
negative and actually about 20 percent
of basal like cancers are hormone
receptor-positive those patients get
included in all under compare fee
studies and the fact that their basal
like is is pretty much ignored in those
studies and i think it should not be
ignored so many of you are probably
familiar with our clawed low subtype
which shows features of mesenchymal
cells as well as epithelial cells and if
we include Clawd and low within the
triple negative distinction it's the
second most numerous group but
nonetheless the basal like stub type is
still 60% or more of triple negative
breast cancers so in my opinion if we're
ever to make therapeutic and biologic
advance
is against the group that is triple
negative we really have to target the
basal-like subtype because it is foreign
away the majority constituent of triple
negatives so the rest of my talk is
really going to be about the basal-like
subtype and what we've learned about it
from a genetic and biological
perspective and then also some of the
implications that has for human
populations so we called it basal light
many years ago in part because of the
staining for Kerrigan's five and six and
17 which were typically cytokeratins
that identify the basal epithelial layer
of your skin or your Airways I won't go
into it today but we believe the basal
life cancers are derived from a distinct
cell type of origin and again 60 to 80
percent of triple negatives have the
basal-like phenotype as shown in the km
plot here in the absence of therapy the
basal like patients have a poor
prognosis and therefore we must pretty
much always offer therapy to these
patients and of course what therapies to
offer them is a critical question I
could argue that we first discovered
basal like cancers through our genomic
studies more than a decade ago and
therefore we had a lot to learn about
them one thing that we've learned over
and over and over again is an
association with p53 mutation status and
in our TCGA Network paper from 2012 what
we could see is that at least 85% of
basal-like cancers have a tp53 mutation
we've also shown correlations with tpc
p53 pathway mutations but this extremely
high mutation rate is it was really
nicely shown in the TCGA work so just a
little bit of review for those of you
not intimately familiar with the Cancer
Genome Atlas Network and our general
approach there the general approach was
to actually utilize multiple genomic and
proteomic technologies
on a common set of samples and what we
did in this publication that occurred
last year for breast cancer was there
are about 500 breast cancers which had
whole exome sequencing gene expression
analysis micro RNA analysis DNA copy
number DNA methylation and reverse phase
protein arrays to look at about 170
proteins and phosphoryl proteins of
course we analyzed each technology
individually but I think the real power
comes from the simultaneous analysis of
all of these technologies at once
because now we can get a more complete
picture than any one technology can
certainly provide so on the next slide
here what we're looking at are what we
call our lollipop plots which identify
the locations of mutations and in this
case we've broken it down according to
intrinsic subtype and then at the far
right here we're showing the mutation
frequency for p53 across the TCGA set of
breast cancers and what you can see is
that the mutation frequency by subtype
varies greatly where it's 85% and
basal-like subtype and its lowest 12% in
the luminal a subtype what makes it a
little more interesting is shown in the
pie charts at the bottom where the type
of mutation also varies according to
subtype where in the basal light group
almost half of the mutations are
nonsense and frameshift mutations
suggesting that these are loss of
function mutations as opposed to
impossible dominant negatives or partial
loss of function missense mutations
which do also occur but again this high
preponderance of nonsense and frameshift
mutations really suggests that it's it's
p53 loss and that you know 85% or more
really suggest no other components of
the pathway really substitutes for p53
and read it
the unique target now in Schad are in
2012 they did a very nice study looking
which included an assessment of the
clonal heterogeneity of triple negative
breast cancers and through analysis of
clonal heterogeneity were able to
identify possibly an order in which some
of the mutations occurred and for these
treat three triple negatives shown here
what we can see is that p53 loss in two
of the three cases likely occurred
within the first clone or the founding
firm and in the second a third example
it was possibly one of the maybe the
second event so not only is p53 loss
extremely common in the basal-like
subtype it also it tends to occur very
early if not as the first event and so I
really think p53 loss is required for
basal-like tumor formation and that it
is one of the founding events for those
tumors now from the Cancer Genome Atlas
we get what we call our significantly
mutated gene list this is the set of
genes that are mutated greater than
check you would expect by chance and
here we've broken it down according to a
tumor in ternary subtype in red we have
the basal-like subtype and the point to
make here is that the significantly
mutated gene list is actually quite
short and maybe only has one or two
three genes or one or two maybe three
genes actually we're statistically on
the list p53 again was 85 percent
frequency next on the list was PHP
Chinese at about a 10 percent frequency
and then our B so the thing to point out
is that you go from one gene at 85% the
next gene on the list that's 10% so in
some sensors there's really only one
frequently mutated gene and basal-like
breast cancer and that's p53 you can
contrast this with luminal a were there
many different genes that's a different
story
what we can also see is that this high
frequency of p53 loss and not many other
genes is extremely reminiscent of what
we saw in the Cancer Genome Atlas when
we studied ovarian cancers where again
p53 was actually mutated in about 95
percent of ovarian cancers the next gene
on the list was Bracken 1 and again it
was a huge jump down to that so here was
one of the first suggestions that there
are significant genetic similarities
between basal-like breast cancers and
serous ovarian cancers and I'll show you
some more examples of that in the next
few slides so when we see this high
frequency of p53 loss and pretty much
and then not much else it makes us
wonder what are some of the other
driving events in basal-like breast
cancer and I think the answer is we can
find many of these other events in the
DNA copy number landscape so in this
publication from my lab from 2011 what
we're showing here is the DNA copy
number landscape
according to tumor subtype so you have a
0% line if you have a peak above it
that's an amplification if you have a
peak below it that's a deletion the
heights of the peaks or the troughs as
an indication of the frequency and then
we further color-coded it and the
regions in black are regions that were
significantly associated with that
particular subtype and not the others so
the impression that I get from this
analysis is that first of all the basal
lights have the most copy numbers are
gains and losses and are often said to
have a sawtooth pattern and it's clear
the genome is very much scrambled and
that they also have the most number of
events that are unique to that subtype
and not seen in the others
so here I'd now focused in on just the
basal-like subtype and highlighted some
of the changes I think we need to pay
attention to our end our importance so
the genes in red are important
potentially important amplification
targets and include a KT three we
high-speed kinase net and EGFR and K
rafts but what I want to also point out
is these genes are rarely mutated so
they're often amplified but rarely
mutated is somewhat of a conundrum
because typically we think of these
oncogenes as being mutated and
inactivated and so as we look at basal
light cancers and triple negative breast
cancers we need to keep in mind these
genes are often amplified but typically
not mutated now the genes in pink were
these regions specific to basal like
cancers and I think that the genes in
pink that are deleted are really going
to be important because these are
identifying again commonly deleted
regions and I think they have them some
important tumor suppressors in them I'm
for Q we have loss of impp for B and F
be xw 7 and then 5q which can often be
the whole chromosome 5q we have we're
highlighting a number of genes in
particular red 17 red 15 you are IMC one
which are required for homologous
recombination mediated DNA repair and
actually in this particular in this
publication if we perform RNA ion rad 17
and red 50 it actually makes the cells
more sensitive to DNA damaging agents
like well PARP inhibitors aren't
directly DNA damaging but inhibit DNA
repair but a loss of red 7950 sensitized
cells to become more sensitive to PARP
inhibitors more
sensitive to carboplatin but there's no
change in their sensitivity sensitivity
to paclitaxel so loss of chromosome 5q
may result in making these tumors more
sensitive to chemotherapy so moving on
the list what else have we learned about
basal-like breast cancers well there's
this intriguing association with brca1
status where it's known that brca1
mutation carriers when and if they
develop breast cancer actually end up
developing
basal-like breast cancers 80% of the
time so somehow their brca1 mutation is
not only predisposing the best breast
cancer but predisposing to one of the
subtypes of breast cancers so this is
another means of implicating homologous
recombination mediated their DNA repair
and again might suggest that basal-like
breast cancers or cancers with bracket1
or back to deficiency may be sensitive
to carp inhibitors and DNA damaging
agents particularly cisplatin and
carboplatin well there goes the light
forgive me there my life went up in the
room
so moving on the list in the TCGA we
performed what was called a MIMO
analysis which is a mutual exclusivity
analysis which looks for common genetic
events within defined pathways and if
you end up finding mutually exclusive
events within a pathway it basically
fingers that pathway as being important
for the subtype you're looking at and it
gives you some of the components that
it's also looking at and what we could
see is that the RB pathway and the Braca
pathway were identified as being
implicated in basal-like breast cancers
which nicely confirmed many previous
results suggesting basil's like have
loss of RB and actually lost the brca1
and actually if we go in and we add up
the germline and some
anok loss rate of brca1 and brca2 what
we can see is that about 20% of
basal-like breast cancers have loss of
one or the other either by germline
predisposition or somatic inactivation
so I think that's significant because
there are studies using Clark inhibitors
and I'm showing you a study here with
the PARP inhibitor a lap rib where if we
look at the waterfall plot what you can
see is that is the brca1 mutation
carriers or brca1 or 2 mutation carriers
that were the ones that were gaining the
greatest benefit from single agent a lap
rib and then that was a there was also a
trend on the bottom left for an improved
survival so I think there is mounting
evidence to suggest that brca1 or 2 loss
could portend sensitivity to lack rib or
and or other Park inhibitors and this is
being formally tested in prospective
clinical studies now if we take this
MIMO analysis using TCGA TCGA data a
step further where we compare breast
luminal versus breast basal-like versus
serous ovarian cancer again this
illustrates the genetic similarity
between basal-like breast cancer and
ovarian cancer where brca1 loss cyclin
e1 amplification RB loss a KT 3
expression p53 loss Mik amplification
are all commonly occurring in the basal
like in serous ovarian so from a genetic
level serous ovarian and basal-like are
much more similar to each other than
either is the luminal breast cancer and
actually this even extends the DNA copy
number landscape where in this slide
here we can see the basal-like breast
cancers are in the middle red is
amplifications blue are deletions we
have ovarian on the far right and there
are a number of characteristic region
pretty much only seen in the basal-like
breast dances and the serous ovarian
which include 3p or excuse me
3q amplification and four cubed loss and
5q loss so that loss of rad 17 and rad
50 was not only occurring in basal-like
breast cancer but also occurs in serous
ovarian cancer so these data and many
others led us in the Alliance which is a
clinical trials cooperative group to run
this triple negative neo edge of at
breast cancer study where were formally
testing the benefit of carboplatin and
bebés news ahmad in triple negative
breast cancers I'm thrilled to say that
this study has completed the cruel and
we were we will report the results at
the 2013 San Antonio Breast Cancer
Symposium now many people think there is
no treatment for triple negative breast
cancer this actually is not true these
patients get multi-agent neoadjuvant
chemotherapy and what we can see on this
slide here is that if we use pathologic
complete response as an endpoint it is
the basal-like subtype that has a pretty
high PCR rate 38% in this study so there
are many basal-like breast cancer
patients who actually gain a significant
benefit from chemotherapy so we do have
a treatment for many of them but of
course we need to do better than just
chemotherapy alone and that's what the
next few slides we'll talk about
although on this slide here i just want
to point out that I believe pathologic
complete response is a good endpoint
that does portend a good prognosis and
that's shown in the middle slide where
in red the patients overall who had a
PCR had a much better survival than
those who did not and if you look at the
far right this is just the patients and
the basal-like subtype those basal-like
patients who have the
see our do you have a good overall
survival but those who do not and a
significantly worse survival and we
really must strive to come up with
improved that our therapies again
particularly for those days like
patients you don't have a complete
response to be able to chemotherapy so
that's where our studies then turn right
we want to find the transducer map
equivalent for the basal-like subtype so
we and many others have gone data mining
to find potential drug targets in the
basal-like subtype and many years ago we
noted that most basal-like breast
cancers highly express the epidermal
growth factor receptor EGFR are also
called her one and actually EGFR
expression is part of our immunity to
chemical definition of the basal-like
subtype so the presence of a known drug
target and a target which often drives
tumorigenesis led us in the
translational breast cancer research
consortium to run this clinical trial on
metastatic triple negative breast
cancers where they received cetuximab
which is a monoclonal antibody against
EGFR or C toxin lab plus carbonyl
platinum the disappointing result was
that the overall response rate was quite
low in this study maybe 10 to 15 percent
at best
so we then wondered why most basal-like
breast cancers Express EGFR yet when we
give the drug that targets that they
have a low response rate so this sent us
back to the bench to do some genomic
based studies and these I think are
summarized in this publication from 2007
and then in the one from 2012 and in
this case what we're showing here is a
cartoon of the EGFR RAF's
MEC pathway where the components in the
path
are color-coded according to their
average expression in the basal-like
subtype versus luminal A's with red as
typically showing a high expression
black average expression and green low
expression I think what you can see on
average is that most things are red in
the basal light group and most things
are green and illuminates suggesting
that the pathway is on the basal-like
subtype and often often lumen rise and
actually at the bottom when we show our
cluster one two and three which were
three related signatures which we
postulate might be indicative of
activation of the her one pathway so
we've ended further statistics and noted
that high expression of the genes which
have pink arrows on them were
statistically associated with the
basal-like subtype and not the other
subtypes and associated that the high
expression of these activation
signatures on the bottom and actually
this could explain some of our results
right for example high expression of K
wrasse might drive the pathway in which
case giving a drug that targets the top
of the pathway may have no effects so in
this slide we visualize the pathway on a
patient from that clinical study of EGFR
inhibition before and after therapy and
what we can see is that this patient was
a non responder they progressed right
through the therapy and if you know you
can see they were low for EGFR high for
K wrasse and high for this gene called
alpha be crystalline high for our
signatures before and after therapy
so in this antidotal example you might
have predicted this patient wouldn't
respond and in fact they didn't
conversely here we have a patient who
did respond high for EGFR low for K
wrasse low for alpha B they had a high
expression of a signature but in the
after treatment and sample it went much
lower alright so here and only again you
might have predicted this patient
wouldn't respond
and they did so in this study we had I
believe 18 patients before and after
therapy and so we were able to look at
these different biomarkers to see if
they predicted response and actually the
high expression of our activation
signature number two in the pretreatment
sample predicted a lack of response and
it actually also predicted a lack of
response or PD progressive disease in
the post treatment sample so this was a
marker predicting resistance and there
were actually three other markers that
also predicted resistance and we looked
at the post treatment sample and those
were proliferation signature claudin low
signature and the carafe signature so
here we're able to identify signatures
of resistance hopefully we can also
identify signatures of response in
future studies so if we now go and look
at the cartoon in terms of data coming
from the Cancer Genome Atlas I think we
have an explanation for why EGFR
inhibition made in this case may not
have worked in triple negative and
basil's or triple negatives and it is
that there are many downstream
activation events including
amplification of TRS amplification of
b-raf and high expression of this gene c
ry a B also called alpha B crystalline
and many of you may not be familiar with
that gene but a number of years ago in
collaboration with Vince crying's we
demonstrated that if you overexpress
this gene in mcf 10a cells it results in
disorganized S&I growth in soft agar
growth in nude mice and interestingly
EGF independent growth and if we give a
MEK inhibitor we can reverse all those
phenotypes so this was the implication
of putting alpha B into the MEK pathway
so all of these studies then kind of
point towards Mack or a downstream
components of the pathway as being the
neck the logical drug target right so
because there are so many activation
mechanisms we should target the bottom
of the pathway was our next thought so
this was then studied in Duncan at all
which is a wonderful study coming from
Gary Johnson's lab here at UNC and what
we looked at here was how the cell
adapts or reprogrammed to when we give a
MEK inhibitor and one of the key
enabling tools here was what are called
multiplex inhibitor beads which allow us
to look at the protein kinase which is
all kinase is expressed in a cell at any
one time and to take repeated
measurements so what we do in these tiny
bead assays are what they've developed
in gary's lab are these basically a
protein affinity column where attached
to inert beads are different kinase
inhibitors and you passed your protein
lysate your cell lysate over the column
and protein kinase is bind to the
inhibitors you then elude the kinases
from the column put them onto the mass
spec machine and then we're able to
quantitate and identify which protein
kinase is in there so the kinase is bind
to the mid beads as both a function of
the affinity and the activation state of
the kinases and in the bottom right is
that this the the data display and in
this display if the kinase if the bar
goes to the right there's more of the
kinase bound you can think of it as
being activated if it goes to the left
you can you're less of it is bound and
you can think of it as being a dividend
so here we're looking on this slide at
the kinase or the Chi no activity
the triple negative actually this is a
known basal-like breast cancer compared
to normal breast tissue and on the far
right is the Western blot or what I'll
call the old-fashioned display that you
can clearly see that this particular
basal-like breast cancer has high
expression of Wrath Mac phosphoryl Mac
earth and phosphor work so so the
pathway looks to be on on the top left
is the new display from the kinda beets
basically showing the same thing so Gary
in his lab and James Duncan first wanted
to look at kind of reprogramming in a
triple negative cell line some 159 I'm
gonna call this quad low cell line and
in response to MEK in addition over a 24
hour time period and on the far right we
have a blow-up showing that MEK is
clearly inhibited
but then what could also be seeing is
that earth over time which is the target
of MEK actually gets turned back on and
then we also notice that some receptor
tyrosine kinase is like pdgfr data and
BDR one also get induced with time so
ddr1 and pdgfr beta are actually part of
a gene family which are inhibited by the
small molecule sarasu nib and and and so
we then perform some combination
experiments so on the bottom left here
what we have is a single agent surrett
single agents Arafa nib basically alone
gave no response and was similar to just
DMS alone on the some 159 cells the azb
elicited a response that was basically
slowing the cell down slowing the cell
line down certainly didn't cause
regression and then if we give a CD and
sarasu t'v we can actually now see some
cell regression so to them
straight that it's possibly pdgfr beta
is the major responder here we did the
genetic experiment where we performed
RNA I against pdgfr beta again it slowed
down the cells and then if we do pdgfr
data SI RNA and the azd we can now hit
that cell growth so to extend these
studies we looked at a mouse model of
triple negative breast cancer what we
call our C 3 T antigen model as shown in
the right this mouse model has
significant similarities based upon gene
expression to human basal like cancers
and on the left what we basically show
is it had the same reprogramming
response as did the human cell line
importantly induction of pdgfr beta and
in this case also the veggie fr2
receptor and so not only is this
reprogramming event conserved across the
you know a mouse model and a human cell
line but it's conserved across species
so we did the same experiment with
adding sarasu nib in this mouse model as
we did in the human cell line and got
the same result so on the top left
untreated tumors grow fast on the top
right treated with Serafina they still
grow fast if you give the MEK inhibitor
alone we get a mixed response if you
give them back and hit butter + Sarandon
we actually get tumor regression alright
so the key here is knowing how the cell
adapts to MEK and hit in the MEK in
addition and combining that is now the
effective therapy so on this slide
sarasu nib as a single agent has been
tried in breast cancer and given a
result that we've seen many many times
in the metastatic setting which is that
we see a progression free survival
benefit as shown on the left but then on
the right this does not result in an
overall survival benefit
the other thing to note is that some of
these kinase inhibitors are toxic these
these authors actually noted this in the
paper and so a word of caution to all of
us as we start to combine these Chinese
inhibitors because I think it's really
going to be the combination of the
kinase inhibitors are but Israel an
effective therapy so on this final side
is kind of a very complicated dish salt
of what's going on here again I'll send
you to read this paper but to try and
make a long story short what happens
when you do MEK in addition on these
triple negative models is that you
inhibit Mack which inhibit Earth Burk
actually was positively inducing MIT so
in the in the absence of Burk activation
Nick Goes Down
mit was actually repressing pdgfr beta
and VBR one
so now pdgfr beta and ddr1 are induced
which then in turn start signaling down
the RAF's neck pine kinase pathway again
turning it back on so if we can give the
MEK inhibitor and an inhibitor of the
reprogramming response in this case sir
afternoon together that is the effective
therapy so of course looking at other
pathways that might be synergistic with
the MEK pathway is a great interest and
and i will argue that the pi3 kinase Akt
mTOR pathway is another such pathway
that is very often this regulated in
basal-like breast cancers potentially
dysregulated more often than the MEK
pathway possibly up to 90 percent of
basal life cancers may have some means
of activating this pathway typically
through loss of ethan and their loss of
impp for B therefore combinations of MEK
inhibitors with mTOR inhibitors or MEK
inhibitors with pi3 kinase inhibitors is
another logical combination to test
we actually did test this at our mouse
models and showed this in this
publication from 2012 where the
combination of a MEK inhibitor a CD
along with the pi3 kinase mTOR inhibitor
bez was the most effective combination
in our t11 claude low mouse model and
also in the c3 tag model so this now may
be an interesting combination to now
begin to test in humans and we're also
in this particular study performing what
we call a window study so in this case
we give a drug to an actual breast
cancer patient for a week in sample the
tumor before and after the treatment and
the hope here is that we can study the
before and after biopsies using genomics
and of course this kind of reprogramming
response to empirically determine in
actual triple negative breast cancer
patients how they reprogram their chi
known in response to MEK inhibition so
that we can identify the potential
optimal partner for meking inhibition
for future studies so that's just some
thoughts on what could be good therapies
for triple negative or basal-like breast
cancer patients there are actually many
other thoughts out there of this but to
summarize these I'll reiterate that
their baseline prognosis is four so we
need to treat them chemo therapy benefit
is high and so we're still likely going
to give these patients chemotherapy the
jury is out on PARP inhibitor benefit in
non BRCA mutant basal-like or triple
negative cancers we also don't know
about carboplatin or angiogenesis
inhibitors again I'll remind you from
Nora San Antonio presentation and more
comments on that I've shown you our data
on the EGFR rafts MEC pathway
pi3 kinase mTOR pathway I think these
pathways are critically important and
likely dysregulated in all basal-like
breast cancers how their dysregulated
tho berries and combinations of these
two may prove important i haven't talked
at all about immune system therapies
I think basal-like breast cancers are
prime candidates for immune system
therapies in part because at least half
of basal-like breast cancers are filled
with tumor infiltrating lymphocytes and
also many of these basal-like breast
cancers show high expression of pd-1 and
PDL one and so we need to test those
therapies in triple negatives and I'm
confident many that will get done so the
last part of my talk I'm going to
completely change gears and discuss the
population-based implications of the
basal-like subtype which was prompted
many years ago by the finding
illustrated on this slide which is that
it was known and and is known and has
been reaffirmed many times recently that
african-americans have a lower incidence
of breast cancer when compared to whites
however they have a higher mortality so
why these african-americans get less
breast cancers but once they get them
they have a worse outcomes figuring this
out is critically important to the
United States and and our health care
system and therefore at the University
of North Carolina and our School of
Public Health a population-based study
was founded called the Carolina breast
cancer study which is a case-control
study which purposely over sampled
Africa African Americans and purposely
over sampled young women with breast
cancer and we know that young women with
breast cancer show this same
interesting phenomenon which was again a
lower incidence of breast cancer but a
higher mortality so once a little boy of
1400 cases were collected we were able
to perform our IHC subtyping on these
cases and to look for possible
interactions between breast cancer
subtype and differences according to
race and age and what we shot what we
identified was that the frequency of the
basal-like subtype varies according to
race and age specifically basal likes
are more frequent in younger women
independent of race and they're more
frequent in african-americans and
actually as you can this is additive
where they're actually the most frequent
in young african-americans
the only other subtype that shows a
difference is the luminal a subtype
which shows the reverse trends it is
more frequent in older women and more
frequent in Caucasians so this finding
in and of itself can explain some of
these racial outcome disparity
differences because it shows that women
with or that african-americans are
getting more of an aggressive breast
cancer subtype and less of the better
outcome luminal a subtype now my
collaborator Fumiya Lipari is extended
these studies to her native country
nigeria and africa which she which shows
an even higher proportion of basal-like
and unclassified and she also in this
study did some comparison to other
published studies and we noted that
Japanese population actually has a even
lower frequency of basal-like breast
cancers so these data suggest that there
are environmental or genetic influences
over your likelihood of the
helping basal-like breast cancers or not
so of course getting at these influences
is critically important this publication
was a california-based a cancer Cancer
Registry study which we confirmed the
findings in this case it's your odds
ratio developing a triple negative
breast cancer the top arrow shows that
if you're younger you're more likely to
have a triple negative if you're
african-american you're more likely
somewhat surprisingly if you're a
Hispanic in California and you are more
likely but if you were Asian Pacific
Islander living in California you're
actually less likely of developing a
triple negative which suggests to me
that there must be a genetic component
to this because now we've got Asians
living in California and they still have
this lower susceptibility now a
confounding feature that all must always
be kept in mind here is that
socioeconomic status is also a slight
contributor to be more likely to develop
a triple negative cancer so together the
possible genetic underpinnings of
basal-like breast cancer susceptibility
a large consortium was formed where we
pooled together 1700 er negative breast
cancers actually was a thousand er
negative breast cancers and 2,700
controls from african-americans and a
gene loss was performed to try and find
genetic susceptibility factors for ER
negative breast cancers and
african-americans there was a very
strong signal which was a snip within
the intron of a church so for once we
had a G wasps hit in the middle of a
gene which we knew something about right
H ster it's the catalytic subunit of
telomerase a gene known to be important
for breast cancer so this this certainly
suggests
to myself each shirt might be important
for basal-like breast cancer so actually
the name of this paper in my mind should
have been triple negative breast cancer
susceptibility not er negative and
here's the reason so in the red box the
ER negative patients were broken into
two groups those that were her2 positive
and those that were her to negative
those that were her2 positive showed
none of the GOI signal it was all in the
triple negative group and I'm gonna
again argue because basil's are the
major constituent of the triple negative
group we are really looking at a
susceptibility factor here for
basal-like breast cancer now the story I
think even gets more interesting and and
what I've just popped up on the screen
here and put in the red box is the risk
allele frequency in african-americans is
actually 57% so the risk allele is not
present that some minor frequency it's
actually the predominant allele and
african-americans and in those of
European ancestors ancestry it's it's
still quite frequent it's there at 27%
and again I want to point out this is a
risk allele for a triple negative breast
cancer even in europeans right and so
this is the this is a frequent allele
and we need to pay attention to it and
it was shown by others consistent with a
lower incidence of triple negatives in
in Asians that it's even at a lower
frequency or in that population so from
some very recent study these results
were confirmed yet again this time using
let's see seven thousand cases and 4141
thousand controls the telomerase snip
was again shown to be a susceptibility
snip the story even gets more
interesting and what they actually
demonstrated as well is that there
actually are protective alleles at this
so we have a lot to learn this study
also showed that this H dirt locust was
the susceptibility allele for ovarian
serous ovarian cancer demonstrating yet
another genetic similarity between
basal-like breast cancer and serous
ovarian cancer there was also another
publication showing that there were
forces of susceptibility low site or
just ER negative breast cancer one of
which is MDM for another gene involved
in the p53 pathway so these data in my
mind again highlight the importance of
p53 function in basal-like breast
cancers and again argue that basal-like
breast cancers certainly er negative
breast cancers are a different disease
from here positive breast cancers so in
this case we're looking at what I call
life history features which are some
known risk factors or protective factors
for developing breast cancer and so
before we did these studies it was known
that having multiple children was
protective of breast cancer in general
but now if we look at breast cancer as
luminal breast cancer or luminal a
versus basal like what we can see is
that having multiple children was
protective for luminal a but it's
actually predisposing a basal-like
breast cancer as was a young age at
first birth and so once again you know
and certainly the observation that a
life history feature is a predisposing
for one and protective for the other
again argues that these are two
different diseases things like
waist-to-hip ratio which is a measure of
obesity in this case was predisposing
for both but particularly this finding
of multiple children protective in one
case and predisposing to the other again
argues these are different diseases so
the last slide here I think or
penultimate slide it shows kaplan-meier
pots plots again illustrating ratio
outcomes austerity differences on our
Carolina breast cancer study in general
showing african-americans are worse
outcome than Caucasians however there
was another intriguing finding which was
if we break this down according to
subtype on the right there was no
survival difference for the basal-like
subtype by race it was the the luminal a
subtype was the only subtype where there
was a statistically significant
difference by race where the
african-americans had a worse outcome
than the whites so this is not only our
african-americans more likely or less
likely to get luminal a breast cancer
but when they get it they still don't
have as good an outcome we don't
understand this particular difference it
may be due to adherence the endocrine
therapy unfortunately we don't have that
data on the CBC s phases 1 & 2
and we also know that even when we
adjust for subtype and tumor stage there
is still a racial outcome disparity
difference so we do not yet have the
complete story and therefore we have
expanded our population-based study to
phase 3 in honor of Jean Lukas Harris
who was the first African American state
senator in North Carolina and who died
of a triple negative breast cancer and
we've now collected 3,000 more cases
again over sampling for
african-americans again sampling for
young women with breast cancer and this
time acquiring the extensive treatment
and outcomes data on these patients so
we can better get at the molecular and
epidemiology roots of racial up compass
parity differences in the United States
so in closing hopefully I've convinced
you that basal-like breast cancer as a
distinct disease different from ER
positive and her2 positive breast cancer
and I'll again argue that if we're if we
are to make progress against triple
negative breast cancer
must target the basal-like breast cancer
subtype it is the dominant biology in
that group basal-like breast cancer
share many similarities with severe
serous ovarian cancers including p53 RB
and Bracker loss and even genetic
susceptibility low side basal X also
show a neat population-based
risk factor profile and many are
chemotherapy sensitive however
additional drugs are needed and in the
long run I believe that the best
personalized diagnostics will be a
combination of assays we're not going to
just sequence your genome we're not
going to just do protein expression for
ER and PR and gene expression assays we
need to do all of these things and we
need to put them all together and our
kind own data also suggests that we may
need to take repeated measurements of
tumors in some cases in order to come up
with the optimal therapy for those
patients so in closing I just need to
thank the many people involved in this
project as you can imagine this is
clearly a multidisciplinary approach
which requires statisticians oncologists
pathologists laboratory basic
researchers geneticists in particular
I'm going to call out the work of Katie
Hoadley who did many of the EGFR pathway
signatures I discussed Bob Milliken who
is now deceased but was the brains
behind the Carolina breast cancer study
Gary Johnson for the kind of essay and
Lisa Carey my my close clinical
collaborator and then Fumio Lipari for
working on the the racial studies so in
closing I'll also point you all to bio
conference live.com for the CME credit
and then thank you all for your time and
attention so I think it's now time to
take questions and let's see first
question is
I can pull up the whole thing maybe
maybe I can't read the whole question
right click okay let me see here
question could you comment on the
article sequential application of
anti-cancer drugs enhance cell death by
a pop tonic signor networks and the
answer is no I'm not intimately familiar
with that paper and I'd have to go look
it up and and I will second question is
what Biot biopsy sampling or statistical
methods do you advocate for addressing
the variation due to intro tumor
heterogeneity from molecular profiling
of cancer samples
does it matter at all it does matter at
all right and and and certainly intra
tumor heterogeneity particularly in
triple negative cancers is an issue that
must be addressed
you know the optimal thing would to do
would be to take multiple biopsies from
the same tumor and to subject each to
our molecular essays most of the time
that's just not practical and and so if
you have the opportunity and certainly
for Diagnostics when we have a
pathologist with a pathology specimen I
always say we want the pathologist to be
a pathologist and to take a piece of the
specimen that they believe to be the
most representative of the tumor and if
the specimen in general shows areas of
high grade or low grade I tend to
advocate to take the area that shows the
most aggressive or
hi great features again if we can if you
can sample multiple areas that would be
great
but again you we need the pathologists
to take the piece they think is best
next question what studies and
treatments are you familiar with for ER
only breast cancer so even though I
didn't talk about er positive breast
cancers there certainly a plethora of
studies out there focusing on you know
certainly various studies for endocrine
therapy sensitivity including
differences and aromatized inhibitors
different ways of inhibiting gr do we
give endocrine therapy for five years or
ten years are some of the pressing
studies I think there here are positives
there also a number of very promising
drugs on the horizon
including cyclin CDK 4/6 inhibitors
which have shown some promise promising
early efficacy in er-positive breast
cancer patients and also pi3 kinase
inhibitors so I haven't seen too much
data on pi3 kinase inhibitors and they
are positives however forty percent or
more of the are positive breast cancer
patients have pi3 kinase mutations so my
hope is that having a pediatric kinase
mutation is a predictor of response to
those drugs that is being formally
tested and so I'll say keep your eyes
and ears open for those results next
question is there any particular somatic
mutation more frequent and basal-like
subtypes well it is p53 mutation right
so that that's pretty much the only
highly recurrent mutation actually in
basal-like subtype or if you looked in
triple negatives right and and then next
on the list is pi3 kinase mutations and
the next
list is RB so I think I think for basil
likes those are really the three genes I
would look at in terms of
somatically mutated genes question 5
what mechanisms might contribute to the
high frequency of p53 mutations in
triple negative cancer cells that's a
good question I don't know if I know
what the underlying selective pressure
is for having p53 loss they'd be such a
required event and I'm going to call it
a require to that so don't think I have
a good answer there but definitely
something we need to figure out the next
question what is the frequency of IGF r1
over expression a triple negative cancer
I don't know the answer to that one I
can say because I don't know the answer
I bet you it's I would think it's not
that frequent or I missed it I will say
and encourage you to go look at the
Cancer Genome Atlas paper and look at
igf-1 R because it actually certainly
there on the DNA copy number studies and
if we're lucky it's there in the rppa
data next question what is your support
of alternative methods in breast cancer
testing other than mamak mammograms wow
this one's certainly out of out of my
area of expertise I know that MRI and
other methods like Tomo synthesis are
being tested in retrospective and
prospective studies we'll have to see
how those compare and that's not all I
can say a last possible question here or
last question is what is the difference
in her two positivity between basil and
luminal the answer is there is a
significant difference in
the frequency and her two positivity in
a basal-like is fairly rare I might say
about 5% 5 to 10% the basil likes our
her2 amplified and in luminal breast
cancers it's probably 20 25 % now with
that said I'm calling our her2 enriched
subtype as a luminal breast cancer so in
this case luminal breast cancer includes
the hurt to enrich the luminal a and the
luminal B subtypes so if you put all
three of those together it might be 20
to 25% certainly if you look at the hurt
to enriched subtype it's about 60 to 70%
of those that hurt to man amplified the
simple answer here is her2 amplification
in the basal is fairly rare it does
occur and from what we've seen those
patients tend to be don't do as great on
trans news as others so another question
what is the role of micro RNAs in basal
life versus serous ovarian and luminal
cancers so this question was somewhat
addressed in the TCGA paper on breast
cancer of 2012 actually I don't know
about serous ovarian cancer we didn't do
that comparison in that paper but the
micro RNA profiles of basal-like breast
cancers were about as distinct as are
the gene expression profiles of
basal-like breast cancers so to make a
long story short there's a unique set of
micro rna's that are that are basically
only in basal like cancers and not in
the others and on the micro RNA level
you could you could you could
distinguish the basil's so with no
further questions I'll thank you all for
your time and attention and look forward
to doing this again in the future if
possible thank you
you